in terms of my own work Leyla just
mentioned one of the new initiatives is
the founding of the Center for Advanced
virtuality so this is a center that's
for pioneering innovation with
technologies of virtuality that include
extended reality virtual reality
augmented reality mixed reality and more
that could include video games social
media but more importantly than that two
new forms unanticipated by any of these
and you could say why virtuality my not
a center for VR or extended reality and
the reason is because one we're
interested not just in the latest
particular technology the latest headset
in a way but rather we're interested in
exploring experiences that are real but
not primarily physical as mediated by
the computer and so what that means is
that if you have somebody for instance
that is harassed online even to the
point of self-harm tragically you don't
want to say well that was just virtual
that wasn't real and if somebody also
has a transformative educational
experience or learn something that they
can apply in their own life you also
don't want to say that that's just
virtual and not real so in other words
we think about the technologies that you
could say paint a layer of imagination
on top of the physical world so there
are four different functions to the
center and so I'll just briefly mention
these there's a studio a lab salon and a
hub the studio is focused on making now
that's new forms of expression
innovation the lab is focused on impact
research you know that is the learning
cognition and really understanding how
do we ensure that this work has made a
kind of positive empowering social
impact the salon is focused on sharing
you know that's capacity building events
here at MIT and collaborations further
afield and the hub is focused on
involvement now that is ways we can
engage the community and other
collaborators within our endeavors and
so now I'll say just a little bit about
my own path you know that sort of got me
to this to this point and that some of
the kind of works
relate to the work of this Center and so
in a way here one of my motivating ideas
is this the AI systems can impact users
behaviors our connections our senses of
self and even our perspectives of others
and furthermore since biases can be
embedded in technologies it's imperative
to consider their social impacts as in
and to do this intrinsically
during the act of inventing them so how
can a AI be used for then for social
awareness and expression well when I
started out doing this kind of work in
in the areas of virtuality people
actually interested in something like
this they're interested in creating a
holodeck from Star Trek and an extra
generation that is a kind of virtual
space where you can get a narrative
experience or kind of thrill ride type
experience and no matter what you do you
get a good story you know that is you
can become another person and enter our
kind of narratives like Sherlock Holmes
and so on so this is well known and it
requires certain kind of technical
facility world modeling character
modeling may be adversarial search so
that you can sure no matter what users
do then the world ends up reading I had
a plausible outcome but what I thought
instead was could we do something a bit
different that is could we use AI in an
improvisational sense to automatically
change stories in the sense of
characters perspectives or what about
the cultural worldview or themes or
metaphors or emotional tone and to me
that required a kind of engagement with
cognitive science what kind of theories
of metaphor and how we could generate
new ideas and new imaginative constructs
and then furthermore how do we formalize
those in a way in that can yield
generative computational systems and so
I'll just mention a couple of works so
begin yeah so actually we've done a lot
of different a lot of different projects
over the years but in terms of the ones
so that I'll mention today I'll start
with this one which is called the Living
Liberia fabric
and so this is a system that was
initiated in affiliation with the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission of Liberia
after 14 years of civil war and the
challenge is unlike the more famous
shooting reconciliation commission that
came out of South Africa and which you
could just point to apartheid and say
that okay well this was in some sense
the spark for the social ill or you
could you could say the shroud of the
social ill you know that we want to
expose and move beyond in this case
there are 15 different ethno-linguistic
groups a series of one-upsmanship and
also it was put in motion by occlusion
between slaveholders within the United
States as well as repatriated African
Americans and became the elite group
within Liberia so we needed to think how
can we tell this story in a way that
respects the multiplicity of the trauma
that took place so used a platform I
created which is called griot which is a
kind of AI platform to help generate
flexible stories that that are different
in terms of theme and content each upon
each execution and so I won't go into
the details are here I mean it's written
up in a number of papers but basically
there's a kind of semantic annotation
that takes place and by analogy you find
the next best clip to fit the
stakeholder group and the theme that you
know that was chosen by the user and so
just to give you a little sense yeah and
so I can't do justice to it with the
time here but just a sense of what this
looks like it's a kind of motika fabric
I mean these were produced in Indonesia
but famously popular within West Africa
also like a lapa fabric on which people
would typically so images into patterns
even of their favorite politician and so
on during during rallies and a similar
kind of phenomena and in this case we
created this kind of work after about a
year of fieldwork engaging the aspera
Liberians Peace Museum experts and
commissioners and so on
so it starts off with as ocean sound and
all the content on text is generated
kind of poetic text and you choose a
stakeholder group at the beginning based
on that stakeholder group it'll put into
motion so we chose here after you
[Music]
now all that that footage was collected
in the field in a kiosk using a system
with agent to help people can work
facilitate people weren't necessarily
printer computationally literate but of
course management and many other animes
and telling the stories that first part
of my life was angry with the
perpetrators which meant these exchanges
when I started working with them I
realized that these young people as as
much victim
and so as she spoke about the child
soldiers we have another set of
potential Clips here and so I'll stop
here here with just you know that work
we can engage it more if you like and
just move on to another system which is
using another platform of our design
this is called grayscale that addresses
sexism in the workplace and it addresses
a particular model using a different
kind of immersive system
it's an epistolary narrative now these
are narratives like they'll take place
over journal entries or some series of
kind of text in this case emails and it
makes you feel like you're a HR manager
in the face of in a kind of melancholy
great corporate environment we have a
model on the backend that's using our
system called chyme area that models
membership in different groups in this
case different types of sexism and then
you have to choose how you respond to
these kind of incidents such as here I
mean this is just one but here Rob is
written to the company list our company
has a dress code for a reason yoga pants
are a unprofessional and be distracting
all right so what do you do in the face
of a series of messages you know that
are I mean this is just one we're
actually I'll say a little bit about the
underlying model so do you then say
something like it is not your policy or
not your responsibility to police others
clothing or do you say something about
the fact that these are being called
distracting is it what in fact is the
issue here and so you have a series of
different kind of responses that are
aligned with different types of sexism
yeah so this is implementing a social
science model of sexism that includes
both the kind of overt hostile sexism as
well as complimentary gender
differentiation that is like well you
must be good at the kind of people
skills you know this this kind of these
kind of issues or protective paternalism
and so on and the system is tracking the
trajectory of your sexist or non sexist
responses and generating a host of
different kind of eventualities
then one day I'll conclude on is a
system that some might have heard about
because this was on display at the MIT
Museum has been shown in tel-aviv and
France and many other places and this is
a system the director actually was a
visiting artist through castor wrote a
grant to bring him here he was also in
my lab the imagination computation
expression lab and cast was very
generous in terms of supporting this set
collaboration so this is a work that
puts you into conversation in a room
that's about as big as the front of this
auditorium like a hotel bar room but
you're in a VR space you have combatants
on either side of the room and those
combatants end up responding to your
body language this is the part that I've
worked on your nervousness bias and so
on and changing the story and stage
staging lighting and even at the end you
look like the combatant that you were at
least comfortable with as you went
through the experience and so you have a
sense of what the space looks like has
three different conflicts has gang gangs
in El Salvador conflict in East Congo
and Gaza and you always get the one that
you are least familiar with at the very
end based on kind of pre-registration
and so I'll wrap up just with a brief
trailer just to give you a sense of work
and then we'll have our next two
panelists
[Music]
- really
[Music]
the enemy was born out of my frustration
as a photojournalist and more
correspondent for almost 20 years I have
photograph conflicts and witnessed the
consequences of huge geopolitical shifts
[Music]
when I became a father I simply knew I
could not keep working on the front
lines
yet I was not done trying to understand
Wars
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh never workers you know about a New
York
[Music]
my friends in Israel when they know I'm
heading for Gaza come help themselves
but to wish me luck and to stay safe
they believe a lot of people in Gaza I
irrational also when I spent weeks
working in Gaza and I'm about to return
to Israel my Palestinian friends are
telling me the exact same thing be
careful there
[Music]
the project is rooted in my experience
as a war photographer going from one
side of the frontline to the other and
finding that the fighters dreams hopes
and nightmares are far more similar and
they are different so there is a bigger
story than the war itself and this is
the one I want to explore and share for
the enemy I am using the latest
technologies in virtual and augmented
reality so you can engage directly with
the combatants and meet them hear them
and feel them the way I did in many part
of our walls you create an enemy as a
kid without having met your enemy
because a society around you has created
an enemy in the other so the question is
could I be you if I was on the other
side
[Music]
so it just as I started then we could
conclude just thinking how AI systems
impact users behaviors connection senses
of self perspectives of others you know
we've had a few examples of this now and
then since biases can be embedded in
technologies it's imperative to consider
and design for their social impacts
thank you very much
you